I enjoy every single day I'm alive I
look at especially the Western World and
everyone's depressed or on medication or
all this crazy stuff and I just think a
bad day is coming
for all of us right for all of us in our
future there's 100 probability that
either we're gonna die or someone we
love is going to die so a bad day is
coming you will have a reason to be
upset soon enough that's a fact why are
you doing it in advance like nothing
nothing's wrong today oh wait a flat
tire like like people are so emotionally
reactive to to low-level stuff I don't
get that I've never been that person
yeah I don't know how long I'll live but
I know I'm gonna enjoy myself every
single second